the films and even some television of
the 70s had a romantic simple
slow-moving almost melancholy quality to
them now as a society we want things in
fast-moving 140-character tweet sore
last things are faster what are your
observations about the style of
filmmaking in the present day 2012
heading the 2000-2013 you know in
contrast that with with the 1970s when
you can't introduce artificial speed hit
two into a scene it's gotta have it's
got to come from within the scene you
know and I pacing of course it's very
important in the film whether there were
films in the past and Phil's the
president you have good pace and other
films no matter how fast they go they're
boring and slow speed is nothing to do
with it and I and I think pass on to
filmmakers of my word my own discovery
that I I grew up as a musician by on the
violin iont eight years old I'm on a
gold medal in my violin at the canadian
national exhibition hey so and it seems
to me that the the Sonata form the
symphonic form is the ideal artistic
form all artists pirates and conditions
of music so in an old cliche you know
how does it how does that how does a
film start well here's a here's how
hidin he would start with the slow slow
into introduction to get you in and
suddenly it changes to a lane road and
the story starts to gallop right and
then what happens next he goes to largo
a slow movement again then he goes to a
skirt so which has got a ton of energy
and then finally it's Allegro
appassionato full of full of passionate
as the words would imply so let's see
mr. needs to be a perfect you know and I
always used that when I go through my
scripts i put music in locations before
he'd seen so that won't forget Allegro
and Dante Largo scelto awake
so not just the overall structure but
even in the within the structure because
pacing comes from contrast not by having
playing every scene fast that's not what
gives you pace but so but to stop your
upstate right every story must have
energy and must have and must come from
the material they give you the energy
you know at the same time I've heard you
talk about that a story shouldn't be
wall-to-wall talking you know it was
getting talking about music and I how
many of you said now that this shouldn't
be water while talking and you have to
leave room for the music there's a story
there yes well I learned that like for
example when I did life at the top with
it and it's a scene with Laurence Harvey
and the man whose wife he seduced and he
they haven't seen together and the
producer wants thinks that you
accelerate you accelerated by cutting
soon as the last word is uttered you cut
that was the old-fashioned way of
editing so does the last word has said
Jonathan XE and that editor was a great
editor Derek Derek said to me no no no
no we want it when he finished his
speaking he gets up and he walks away
from the camera would you have him and
you see this broken man that's just as
important as what he said he said he
said it he said eat what he said was
angry and aggressive but Dennis he walks
away you know it's the whole thing the
whole experience with his wife having an
affair with his men destroyed him and so
he says and the music will do that as
well as the picture that you have and
you gotta leave room for the music of
course you know that's very important I
love music as I grew up as a musician so
I think music is one of the most
important elements in filmmaking and I
always work very closely with my
composers and tell them what I want well
what the music to say and again like I
said earlier it doesn't shouldn't be
saying the same thing as the picture
sometimes sometimes it should underline
the
other times it should imply something
else about their about the picture but I
you know one of the things that it's
hard to learn and I learned from Michael
Angelo Tonioli the great Italian
director I won't go into a long story
about him but he by happenstance because
his producer was a friend of mine he
asked me to he couldn't he thought that
blow up was too long and asked me to
help him cut it and make suggestions for
cuts because he liked my film life at
the top and it was a young director you
want a young director to do it so I did
it and used what 15 minutes on my cuts
for blower and then later on we met in
Rome he took me the water near the
dinner with him and one of the things
that he said to me was that I said to
him why do you always have eight writers
credits on the screen and he said you
see Ted when we Italians when we do
cinema we write I get this very great
writer I forget his name now domenica or
something he does all he did all the
great Italian films he said we work
together and we write the film as if it
is a silent film so the whole story is
told pictorially and the dialogue is not
very important see we consider dialogue
unlike you Hollywood directors we
consider dialogue to be sound effects
you see a door slam you have to yell at
slam don't you but that's not what's
important it's important that the door
has been placed as a barrier between the
husband and the wife so you have but you
have to have a select that's what I said
all my scenes the scenes are
communicated pictorially what I want to
say then later on what happens is who
should we get to right he's who's good
at husband and wife scenes we have six
husband and wife scenes in this picture
who's good at David Brin Brandon he's
great he's great at husband get him in
so David comes in and he writes these
gates into his vengeful husband why he
was away he gets okay then we have seen
that requires
the idea heat broadens writers who
specialize in whatever things he wanted
but he said he didn't think was very
important he said just had to sound
convincing but the story and the
situation and the relationships are done
pictorially and I learned a lot from him
then a big influence on me that let
dinner that don't think of communicating
the story verbally verbally should be
the icing on the cake a kid should be
the pictures
you